you're in a marvel franchise now you're
the voice of marvel's what is it modok
mo doc uh it's a show now on hulu
uh that i co-created with a this
brilliant writer named jordan bloom and
modoc is
modoc is basically the most
crapped upon marvel super villain his
name stands for
uh mobile organism designed only for
killing he is a gigantic
floating head in this weird suit with
these tiny little arms and legs and
like jack kirby created him on a bad day
like he was he
either had like some bad corned beef
he's like oh god
and this drew this giant angry head and
from the get-go
all people do is make fun of this poor
guys we're like we this is going to be
our marvel show the worst
super villain in the marvel universe we
kind of go into his life
where he's determined to conquer the
world
but unlike those idiots dr doom and
madam mask
who can't also conquer the world and
have a family and children i'm gonna do
both
so he he is determined to have a nice
wife and kids in the suburbs but then
also
destroy the planet at the same time it's
just it's it's complete
delusion and sadness and it was so fun
to do but this is i mean you're working
with the marvel people and they kind of
own
you know deluxe entertainment now there
must be great perks working for the
marvel
oh my god yeah you get all kinds of um
uh oh god oh my god there's stuff i
can't talk about there's stuff that i've
seen that i can't talk about yet
right oh boy that sounds ominous no but
i'm just saying
they're like we get to see stuff that's
up what do they do to you
yeah well no i could tell you one thing
in next in 2022 they're going to do a
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
super
and the one thing that was weird about
doing modoc was we asked for characters
from the marvel kind of toy box that
we're like well they'll just say no to
this one but we'll be able to get this
one
right they said yes to every thing that
we asked for
every character we wanted to use or like
go right ahead and we're like
really and they're like oh absolutely
but then there were these other
random minor characters like there's
this one guy named stilt man
who was one of daredevil's thank you for
one guy
yes final yes
it is and holy [ __ ] he's on stilts yeah
he is literally tore his mask off
[Applause]
it is like something you guys would
create for one of your
sketches it is a and he's exactly what i
just said he's a guy who has these legs
that he can make really long and just
kind of go up like be
tall and grab things out of buildings
it's stiltman
and so we're like we want stilt man for
this one scene and they were like
no you can't have stilt man we're like
i'm sorry we can have
iron man and mr sinister but we can't
have stiltman
no which makes me think are they going
to use still man
and also it sounds like they're going to
use them for something major and bigger
like
did they did they get joaquin phoenix to
agree to places
that's going to be there i don't know
but like it's so amazing something big
is in the works for stilt man and you
stumbled into it yeah
i mean it was like just so intriguing
the stuff that that's going on there